eine weitere sache die mir vorhin
aufgefallen ist ich weiß nicht ob wir
das hier einmal zeigen können weil da
wird auch in den nächsten wochen
tatsächlich darüber zu reden sein wie
die medien über die bei und da geht es
auch besonders um die öffentlich
rechtlichen medien
aber auch viele magazine viele zeitungen
in deutschland das ganze medienbild wie
die medien in deutschland über die
wähler berichten wir reden jetzt auf
einmal ganz viel über die zukunfts
koalition und die jungen wähler und da
ich halte das hier einmal kurz in die
kamera sieht man eine hoch interessante
statistik nämlich wahlverhalten nach
altersgruppen unter 25 jahren sehen wir
hier den gelben balken massiv nach links
aus schlagen und den grünen bei 23
prozent der unter 25 jährigen haben die
grünen gewählt mit der fdp 22 prozent
der unter 25 jährigen die fdp gewählt
also fdp und grüne gleichauf wenn wir
uns die erst wieder anschaltet ist das
verhältnis genau umgekehrt 23 prozent
für die fdp 22 prozent für die grünen
und jetzt erinnern wir uns mal an die
letzten wochen haben wir dann nicht in
jeder talkshow in deutschland wenn es um
die jungen leute in deutschland ging
vertreter der grünen und von freddys for
future gesehen ging es da nicht
ausdrücklich immer um klima und grüne
politik ging es dann nicht ausdrücklich
um eben genau diese eine politische
richtung die angeblich für die jungen
menschen in deutschland stand wir sehen
es jetzt bei den wahlergebnissen ganzes
deutlich alles was uns in den letzten
wochen in den letzten monaten dieses
wahlkampfs über die jungen menschen in
deutschen medien verkauft worden ist wie
die sind und was die wollen nur luisa
neubauer nur lastenfahrrad
und und nur
logischerweise die grüne klimapolitik
nichts davon hat gestimmt das war exakt
in dieser gruppe die hälfte der wähler
die andere hälfte der jungen wähler
befindet sich in genau dem lager wovon
in deutschen medien immer behauptet
worden ist dass das für junge wähler
also nun gar nicht in frage kommt
neoliberal klientel-politik
porsche-fahrer zahnärzte er damit wollen
junge menschen deutschland nichts mehr
zu tun haben wir sehen jetzt an den
wahlergebnissen nicht aber das ist eine
wichtige lehre des gestrigen feiertags
das was dort erzählt worden ist war
einfach komplett von vorne bis hinten
falsch
also ich versuche das gerade
nachzuvollziehen julian unter 25 jahre
wahlverhalten nach altersgruppen da
haben fdp und die grünen die meisten
stimmen bekommen das heißt die jungen
leute sind in der tat diejenigen die die
grünen ja das haben mindestens einen
punkt um als mein punkt ist dass nicht
alle grün alle jungen leute grün wählen
sondern die hälfte der jungen leute in
dieser altersgruppe eben die fdp gewählt
hat eine alt eine partei die in keiner
der talkshows wenn es wenn ihr junge
leute in talkshows gesehen habt dann
habt ihr nie in ich schwöre ich könnte
mir keiner einzigen torchance zeigen aus
den letzten vier monaten in der irgend
jemand junges gesessen hat und gesagt
hat ich will fdp ich will liberal wir
brauchen nicht mehr grüne
regulierungswut wir brauchen nicht mehr
grüne verbote sondern wir brauchen genau
das gegenteil wir brauchen mehr freiheit
wir brauchen mehr eigenverantwortung
diese position ist in deutschen medien
sowohl öffentlich rechtlicher sei
rechtlich obwohl sie bekannt war die
umfragen waren ja die ganze zeit so ja
und meine tochter ist beispielsweise 25
jahre alt und sie hat gesagt in ihrem
freundeskreis willen alle entweder grüne
oder fdp genau das sind die beiden in
anführungsstrichen hippen partei und die
eine hälfte dieser realität ist in den
deutschen medien ich würde sagen sehr
konsequent und sehr bewusst ausgeblendet
worden weil man eben sich darauf
versteifen wollte dass die jungen
menschen grünen wählen und wir sehen
jetzt dass stimmt exakt zur hälfte und
die andere hälfte der realität sie daher
ein deutlich differenzierteres bild
gezeichnet hätte ist einfach komplett
weg weil wir vielleicht weil wir
journalisten alle älter sind und ob das
überhaupt nicht vorstellen können na ja
ich würde sagen er hier bei bild und
auch durchaus bei axel springer bei den
kolleginnen und kollegen von der welt
kann man sich das durchaus sehr
vorstellen aber wir machen ja noch nicht
die mehrheit der deutschen
medienlandschaft aus wir sind zwar groß
aber wir sind sicher nicht die werte
deutsche medienlandschaft und in der
mehrheit der deutschen medienlandschaft
kam dieses thema junge menschen eine
liberale freiheitliche partei wählen
wollen in keiner weise vor und da muss
man so viel wie jetzt über
aufarbeitungen sprechen so viel die cdu
jetzt über aufarbeitung spricht wenn man
diesen trend komplett verkennt dann muss
man sich ja am ende fast vorwerfen
lassen da wahlkampf gemacht zu haben und
bewusst versucht hart zu haben dass man
eine gewisse altersgruppe einer gewissen
altersgruppe suggeriert ihr dürft nur in
diesem camp nämlich nur bei grün wählen
glücklicherweise sind die wähler daran
einem ende in deutschland ja frei und
zeigen dann durch ihre entscheidungen an
der wahlurne wie sie wirklich denken
aber es ist definitiv in der
berichterstattung viel zu wenig vorgibt
[Musik]